silence ou tome et je commence quand je
veux dans la période de crise que nous
traversions il ya sans doute en
direction des jeunes et aux fonds en
direction de chacun d'entre nous trois
messages le premier c'est évidemment la
période de vaccination dans laquelle
nous sommes
qui va encore s'accélérer et qui va
permettre au fonds de retrouver des
relations sociales plus normal et qui
mieux que les jeunes seront sensibles à
l'idée qu'une pourront retrouver aussi
rapidement que possible une vie sociale
plus normal vie culturelle plus normal
une vie sportif que normal une vie
éducative plus normal et puis le sujet
de l'entrepreneuriat du monde de
l'entreprise je pense que est d'ailleurs
souvent les chefs d'entreprise de dix
ils ont une responsabilité dans cette
période particulière très grande c'est
celle d'offrir un stage d'offrir la
capacité à un apprenti de venir et puis
la capacité à des jeunes dû trouver leur
premier emploi y compris dans une
période de crise économique qui
forcément difficile la seule question
pour ceux qui sont en responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est d'accompagner les
jeunes de les encourager et de leur
donner la capacité à réaliser ce qu'ils
auront à réaliser deux rêves qu'ils ont
à réaliser deux projets et puis ce
qu'ils auront à réaliser aussi des
grandes transformations je pensais la
transformation écologique aux grandes
transformations mondiale qui sont à
l'oeuvre
et qui mieux que les jeunes pour porter
ses envies de choses différentes et de
relever les défis qui sont devant nous
et donc au fond s'il y avait un appel à
lancer aux jeunes et à la jeunesse
ça serait un appel à garder leurs envies
et à garder leurs rêves
parce que demain on aura besoin d'eux
pour construire tout ça